john do you ever use this in one way or
the other by saying i don't think you
can do this to motivate them to to prove
you wrong or
more general question of um
you know
the the mental toughness required to
achieve
or confidence required to achieve
greatness like what's your role as a
coach when you have these two athletes
with regards to your first question
would i ever say to someone
you can't do this
as a kind of reverse psychology i know
um my job is to prepare people first and
foremost with their skills and uh as
gordon pointed out earlier if you're
in any way a rational human being and
you're noticing
that you're getting tremendous success
with a given move in the gym against
high level opponents who
give a good read on what your actual
opponent in a competition is like
you would have to be a [ __ ] to not
recognize that kind of success and say
this is something i should be building
into my game and you will carry the
confidence that you earned in the gym
into the arena
so i never try to use
reverse psychology i build up uh
everything i do in terms of confidence
is to give people physical skills i know
people say oh this physicality on the
one hand is mentality on the other and
confidence is
squarely in the the mental aspect of the
game
but all the underpinnings and beginnings
of confidence are physical
okay a rational human being will see
where they're having success and where
they're having failure and confidence
will
surround those areas where they're
having success and will degenerate in
cases where they're having
failure
so my job as a coach is to set them up
for success in the gym with a given set
of skills and
i don't have to do anything
psychologically after that
i just
if i can set you up to be highly
successful with a given move or a set of
tactics 10 times in a row against
quality opposition in the gym
i don't have to do a damn thing when it
comes to instilling confidence i i will
tell people hey you're doing a really
good job with that move it's working
well for you
but
when they're not in agreement i'm not
trying to force anything on them they're
recognized they were they already
recognized that long before the words
came out of my mouth
but on the other hand intelligent
rational people will recognize when
they're failing with given moves and no
amount of talk on my part can ever
change that
if i teach gordon
a given arm lock and
15 times in a row he tries it over a
month and all 15 are failures there's
nothing i can say verbally to come up
the goal and say hey you're really good
at that move he's going to look at me
say [ __ ] i'm terrible at it. and
that will create a crisis of confidence
where gordon no longer believes the
words coming out of my mouth
so i will never compromise that but
isn't there a lot you just said 15.
you have to believe
that uh
doing this arm lock 15 times over a
period of a month is worth it because
eventually you might get it like yeah
that's a separate issue that that's a
separate issue that um
there are times where i've
more or less pushed athletes to
go in a certain direction for example um
when i first met gary tony he never had
a guillotine strangle and i i would say
don't carry you know
you're a scrambler like one of the
greatest weapons that scramble can ever
develop as a guillotine like it should
be in your arsenal
and he was like no i just scrambled for
the back and i said well there's going
to be a day you can't take someone's
back
and it's always good to go to strangle
from front and back okay of course we
all prefer strangles from the back that
makes sense
but there's going to come a day where
it's going to be useful for you and so
that was one of the few times where i
put my foot down and said you're
learning this shut the [ __ ] up
and um uh he like literally wouldn't
teach him any uh anything else until he
got a gay teen gary would like ask him a
question he's like let's see your
guillotine
and um for the first three months as
gifted as as gary turner is in learning
most moves most moves gary gets it like
in in minutes there was something going
on with gary just couldn't get a
guillotine on people
and uh finally after around three months
he started having some success until
ultimately became one of his best
weapons
um
we had to go through like 15 different
variations of guillotine until he found
one which actually worked reliably for
him and that was one of the few times
where i put my foot down and said no you
you have to learn this so the long
search had to do more with the physical
characteristics like you couldn't figure
out the right like it made sense it made
sense in the case of garryton because
there were more opportunities per minute
of his grappling for guillotines uh that
the investment and time was worth it for
another athlete i might have said well
he hardly ever gets in the situation but
front headlocks are guaranteeing so it's
not even worth investing the training
time